so anyways our speaker is olga bain she
is a senior data scientist at
jw player and she has a
phd in
molecular biology and genetics and for
the
focus code of conduct please
everyone be nice to each other and
since this is about her i will let her
kick things off so as steven said my
name is olga bain i am a senior data
scientist at jw player
and i'll be talking today about some
predictive modeling that we did for our
video advertising marketplace
so jw player is a video technology
company
and we power video for over 12 000
leading publishers and broadcasters
we are actually the number one source of
video views on the open web outside the
wild gardens of facebook and youtube and
we see hundreds of millions of video
plays daily across the world
and we use our scale
uh to build data products to help our
customers so we have a recommendations
product that helps surface relevant
videos
um
we have an article matching product that
helps publishers add relevant video to
any article and the product i'll be
talking about today is our video at
targeting product which helps
advertisers identify high quality ad
impressions
across our publishers sites
so
a lot of our publishers monetize their
video content with ad impressions
i told you that we see hundreds of
millions of video plays daily we also
see hundreds of millions of ad
impressions daily
and uh
jw player runs an advertising
marketplace that allows publishers to
auction their ad opportunities and
here's how that works so a video player
on one of our publishers sites
will send an ad request that indicates
that there's a ad slot that can be
filled by an advertisement and then
advertisers will bid um
to place on ad impression and so maybe
apple is very interested
in uh placing an ad impression in the
slot and they'll bid a lot of money
let's say amazon is also interested but
willing to pay a little less and geico
is not interested um
in placing this impression
uh apple will win this auction and will
place their impression in this ad slot
so why do these advertisers use our
marketplace in the first place
uh well it's because um they are
interested in very often interested in
targeting specific segments so a lot of
advertisers want to place their
advertisements uh in front of people in
specific geo locations some advertisers
also want to target certain video
categories and other advertisers want to
make sure that the videos that they're
placing their video ads on are brand
safe
and this context is known when the video
player embeds on a page
so for this video we might know that the
viewers in canada
the video category is home and garden
and this video is brand safe
and so advertisers are going to use this
information
at the time of the ad request to
determine whether they should bid to
place that impression and how much they
should pay for
and in addition to context advertisers
are also really really interested in
hitting certain ad performance targets
so if an advertiser pays to place an ad
they
would prefer that the viewer is who is
watching this ad is engaged and there
are
several metrics of ad engagement that
are used
so some advertisers care about ad
ability
and there is
a couple different standards for how to
measure that other advertisers care a
lot about ad completion and some are
monitoring whether their ads are audible
and viewable and complete
and so an advertiser might
set an ad performance goal for a
campaign that says the goal is for 70
percent of ad impressions
place to be viewable by the iaea
standard
and the tough thing here is that ad
performance is unknown when the video
player embeds on a page
we don't know
whether the viewer will watch the ad and
we don't know whether the viewer will
complete the ad
at the time that this player embeds
and so typically if advertisers care
about ad performance
um they're gonna use historical ad
performance data to inform their buying
decisions
and here's how that might go um
an advertiser might
set a certain ad performance goal
they'll say we want to add iab
viewability to be greater than or equal
to 70 for this campaign for example
and then an ad slot will become
available on a video play on a specific
page domain the advertiser will look at
the historic page domain level
um
iabv ability and only bid to place an ad
impression if the historical viewability
rate is greater than their
target
and so what this means is that
advertisers are making buying decisions
at the level of the page domain
so i'm plotting here um
impressions per page domain versus
ad ib ability rates on this page domain
so each here is
a single page domain
and if we have a campaign that wants to
hit an id the ability greater than 70
then
um
this uh
advertiser will typically only bid to
place impressions on those page domains
with
a viability of greater than 70
historically and they're going to ignore
all these page domains to the left
and so we wondered can we use data from
the video player to improve ad
performance prediction
and we actually built models for five
different metrics so we built models for
three uh viewability metrics as well as
ad completion and at audible and
viewable and complete
and today i'll just talk about
one of these models which is a model
predicting at iad viewability
um
so at ib viewability is defined as 50 of
the ad in view for two consecutive
seconds
this is a
a metric that's that's very often
um measured by advertisers so this is
where we started
and so our vision here is to predict
whether an ad will be viewable at a
request time using signals available
prior to the ad request
we're going to do this at request time
because this is when um
the advertiser decides whether or not to
bid to place an ad impression so uh we
need to make the prediction before that
and we're going to be using signals
available prior to that request because
this is the only information that that
player has
um
access to
we're gonna compare uh this prediction
to the advertiser's performance goal
then to determine whether the advertiser
should bid to place the ad
and the reason that we can
build these models is because we collect
data from the player on every video play
and every ad impression so we know what
happened on each video plan at
impression and we can use this data to
train and test our
models so uh i told you that advertisers
typically use historical page domain
level ad the ability data
to predict whether the ad will be
viewable
and so this is a feature that i'm going
to use
in the baseline model
uh to predict whether the atom would be
viewable
in our real-time model we're going to
add some um
some very useful features that are only
known to the player so first of all
because we are the player not only do we
know add viewability across a page
domain we also can calculate add
viewability for each individual video so
we're going to add that as a much more
granular
um
historical metric and then we'll also
add in some real-time signals from the
player
and predict will the ad be viewable
uh so our workflow here is that first
we're going to identify those real-time
signals available in the player prior to
the ad request
we're going to train and test the model
on yesterday's impressions
and we're going to determine which
signals are predictive of ad viewability
and uh for those real-time signals that
have some predictive power uh we can
broadly
uh
bucket them into into one of three
categories so the first is player state
this is things like player viewability
or player size
the second is context
so things like what country the viewer
is in and what device they're using and
also user behavior
this is the first video that the viewer
watched
um or is it
or have they watched a lot of videos
and what was their engagement for
example on previous ads
and so in principle we can
use any number of models to try and
predict at iab viewability but we do
have some preferences
a simple model is preferable
if it has enough predictive power it's
going to be easier to actually implement
in the player
it's going to make productions faster
and we also prefer an interpretable
model
this is going to make it easier for us
to understand which signals have
predictive power
and understand how offline performance
compares to online performance
and it's also definitely going to help
us troubleshoot any unexpected things
that we might see once this model is
actually making predictions in the wild
and so all of this led us to um
use a logistic regression model to make
this viewability prediction
and we expect our real-time model to
outperform the baseline for the
following reason
so
uh as i told you
uh using the baseline model we're going
to make decisions at the level of the
page domain
let's say two page domains a and b
uh page domain a has a relatively low
historical ad viewability and page
domain b has a relatively high
historical availability
our baseline model is going to predict
um every ad on the page
uh to be not viewable
and it will predict every add-on page
domain b to be viewable
our real-time model is going to allow us
to identify high quality impressions on
this otherwise lower quality page domain
a and it should also allow us to
identify impressions that won't be
viewable on page domain b
and this is because we make predictions
for each ad request using features
specific to that ad request
and if our real-time signals really
improve predictions then this top row
should mean that we identify more
viewable impressions and the bottom row
means that we should reduce non-viewable
impressions
this is going to impact both the scale
of the campaign and the performance of
the campaign
um
in data science terms when we talk about
campaign scale we're really talking
about recall so of
viewable impressions how do how many did
we correctly identify as viewable
and when we talk about performance we're
talking about precision so of those
impressions that we
predicted would be viewable how many
were viewable
and so these granular predictions are
going to
allow us to identify high quality
impressions on otherwise included
excluded domains so whereas with the
baseline model an advertiser might
totally ignore um all the the domains
with an ad id
less than their target
our real-time model should allow them to
pick out those high quality impressions
even on these domains
and so here
i am showing the results of our offline
model training and testing
and i'm plotting here viewability versus
scale
so ideally we want to maximize
viewability and scale for every single
campaign meaning we want to be
in the top right hand corner of this
plot but there is always a trade-off
between the two if a campaign asks for
really high viewability
then uh
they will have lower scale but the
important point uh from this plot is
that at every
value of scale the real-time model
achieves a higher viewability than the
baseline and at every value of
viewability
the the real-time model achieves a
higher scale and so what this means is
that if a campaign for example asked for
75 viewability
with the baseline model
we would be able to identify
just under 60 of high quality ad
impressions and our real-time model
identifies almost all of them
if a campaign asks for 80 viewability uh
then this increase in scale and becomes
even larger when we look at our
real-time model compared to the to the
baseline
so our offline model training training
look really good and we put this model
uh we did sort of some work to
implement this model to make predictions
online
so we are training the model
daily on yesterday's impressions
server side we're using the psychic
learn library and python
we're dockerizing model training and
scheduling it daily on airflow uh
through airflow and then our models are
serialized to s3
and then client side we have a plug-in
that we call the inference plug-in
that's going to measure those real-time
features that are required for the model
it's going to combine those features
together with any pre-computed
historical
measures that we use in the model and it
will make predictions at request time
currently it's making hundreds of
millions of predictions daily
and
influencing a lot of
um
buying decisions
and of course now that it is making
predictions out of the wild we need to
evaluate how the model is performing
online
this is
especially crucial because there are key
differences between our offline training
and online model performance
so our model is trained
and tested across the whole jw player
network but a single ad campaign
places impressions on only a subset of
videos playing through our player
uh this is because a lot of times
on top of ad performance campaigns are
also targeting other segments so this is
going to
narrow the scope of or the number the
impressions that they might place on
add-on
and also if even if a campaign bids to
place
an ad impression uh they don't always
win that auction
and so all of this is really impossible
to simulate offline
so when we did look at
online model performance we we saw um
that the real-time model did outperform
the baseline strategy
um for campaigns with a relatively high
ad iab ability requirement so here i'm
applying again viewability versus scale
for just two campaigns
the dotted line um
is the ad the ability requirement in
this case both campaigns are asking for
seventy percent
uh in gray is what the baseline model
would have achieved in terms of the
ability of scale and then blue is what
our real-time model achieved you can see
that for both of these campaigns the
model achieves a higher viewability as
well as um
the real-time model
also
identifies more high quality impressions
for these campaigns
we also had some campaigns that
required um a fairly low at iab
viewability rate relative to
the viewability across our network
um
and
we saw here that our real-time model and
the baseline strategy actually achieved
a really similar performance on scale
and and this was expected so
kind of the viewability that's required
is is
much lower than the viewability across
our network than
achieving this viewability requirement
is easy both models
outperform on viewability and both
models
identify almost all of the high quality
impressions
and so if i now um
combine
model performance over all campaigns and
overall impressions uh we can compare
how the baseline and real-time model
perform overall in terms of viewability
and scale
uh
uh on viewability we
improved the ability a little bit from
the baseline of 69 viewability our
real-time model achieves
75 but the real game here isn't in the
scale
so with the baseline model overall that
model could identify just under half of
the high quality impressions and a
real-time model identified almost eighty
percent of those high quality
impressions
so this marketplace should benefit both
advertisers and publishers
um
i don't advertisers can use our data to
target specific audience segments and to
reach an engaged audience
and publishers should get more ad
revenue because advertisers are willing
to spend more money on high quality ad
impressions
so this model was running online and we
were
training
the model every day and seeing a lot of
precision recall curves or viewability
scale curves um
that look as expected uh which is what
i'm showing on the left where the
real-time model outperforms the baseline
and then one day we saw a precision
recall curve that looked very strange
where there's this dip
in precision and this is actually true
for both the real-time model and the
baseline models
and after a lot of research to figure
out what was going on we found the
source of this edge case which was the
following
so both our
real-time model and the baseline model
have this historical domain ad
viewability feature
and we're taking a seven-day average of
historical domain ad viability for this
feature uh and then we're our train and
test set comes from
uh day eight
and so on this day eight with this edge
case there was one single large
publisher
that uh had um
a really significant drop in
uh historical domain ad viability that
the model couldn't account for and so to
mitigate this
we added one additional feature to the
model in addition to this existing
seven-day average historical feature we
also added a divergence feature
where we subtract uh the last the
previous day's uh historical domain
aviability from the seven day average
for most page domains this number is
going to be close to zero but um in
cases where
there is a big difference uh between
this most recent um
and the ability metric
we're going to allow our model to
account for this
and so um
on the left again is the precision
recall curve that we expect in the
middle is this
precision recall curve that we saw one
day
that looked very weird and now if we add
the divergence feature to our model and
train and test that model on the same
data set
that
resulted in this edge case curve we see
that we can restore
model performance for both the baseline
and the real-time features
all right in the real-time model sorry
so up next we are building a series of
feedback loops to dynamically adjust
decision thresholds
so currently we take the model's
prediction
and we compare it to the advertiser's
performance goal to decide whether the
advertiser should bid on this impression
that means that if our prediction is uh
70
for an impression and the advertiser
asked for
anything
below this requirement
then we'll we'll
call this a high quality item question
for this campaign
um
this means that the performance goal is
a static
decision
threshold and the strategy very often
results in these cases where
um we achieve a much higher viewability
with our model than the campaign is
asking for so here's one example where
the campaign asks for
65 percent of the ability uh our model
achieves higher than 90 percent of the
ability
hey olga or we're down to the last five
minutes uh we've got a couple questions
yeah want to start tackling them or
finish up sure i just have one more
slide after this and i'm happy to answer
questions
um
yeah so uh we're building a series of
feedback loops that are that are going
to
decrease
this viewability back toward the
performance requirement
um and this will allow us to increase
or increase campaign scale even more
um
so just to summarize uh we have an
advertising marketplace that should
benefit both publishers and advertisers
uh by identifying relevant high-quality
ad impressions we can use real-time
signals from the video player to predict
ad performance ahead of an impression
if advertisers use our real-time
predictions they can reach their
performance goals and maximize scale and
some really careful modeling monitoring
allowed us to identify and mitigate an
unexpected edge case
thank you for listening i'm happy to
take questions i do want to just mention
quickly that we are hiring
um on our team a senior data scientist
and a product analyst we also have a few
data engineering roles open so if you're
interested in any of those um
please contact me
um but yeah happy to take questions
oh cool all right i've got a couple that
came in through the chat how do you get
the data about ad impressions for the
model
so um we send uh
data back
during the course of a video play um
and we also sent some data back during
the course of an ad impression so we
know for example when an ad impression
happened uh did the
uh was it viewed did someone scroll away
did they complete that um so we collect
a whole bunch of of data from every
single video play
thank you very much for your time uh is
there anything else you'd like to
like to add before we uh wrap up because
it looks like you're the last speaker in
this particular session that was all for
me i'm i'm very happy to move over to
slack if anyone has any additional
questions
you